il était une fois une ville non
loin d'une grande ville que traversait ma route
mais c'était une ville de ceux qui voulaient
être laissés seuls
je viens de terminer
ici en ville et ensuite je vais
partir tu viens avec moi tout de suite
puis jette un œil au doozy je n'ai pas d'
ours à tuer en série à la morgue comment
voudrais-tu collaborer sur un livre
sur  ça tu veux dire que tu viens juste en
bas de la route tu m'as croisé mais tu peux
m'appeler VB c'est bien
quel est ton vrai nom hey Bobby c'est tout
Baltimore aime écrire ce livre avec
toi as un siège dis moi ce que tu as
c'est un travail d'un  tueur en série
ce n'est probablement pas un enfant c'est lui qui les
infecte je veux savoir la vérité
il y a des conséquences quel choix ai-je